life is suffering right indisputable
what do you do about that you you
voluntarily accept it and then strive to
overcome the suffering that's a
consequence of that and you do that for
you and you do that in a way that makes
it better for other people and then that
works and one question might be well how
well does it work and the answer is you
the only way that you can find out is by
trying it that's it
if that's the extension element of it
the proof is to be derived by the
incarnation of the attitude in your own
life no one can tell you how it will
work for you it's the thing that your
destiny is to discover that and you have
to make you have to make the decisions
to begin with it's like because you
can't do this without commitment you
have to commit to it first that's the
act of faith that that Kierkegaard was
so insistent upon you have to say I'm
going to act as if being is good I'm
going to act as if truth is the pathway
to enlightenment I'm going to act as if
I should pursue the deepest meaning
possible in my life and there's there's
reasons to do none of those they're real
reasons so it's really a decision but
you you can't find out what the
consequence of the decision is unless
you make the decision I think the same
thing happens when you get married by
the way is it if you think you might
leave you're not married and then you
think well the marriage didn't succeed
it's like well maybe you were never
married
because the rule is you don't get to
leave and there's a reason for that rule
now I'm not saying that there aren't
situations where there should be
exceptions made for that that's not the
point the point is that there's some
games you don't get to play unless
you're all-in and the other thing that's
so interesting about being alive is that
you're all in no matter what you do
you're all in this is gonna kill you so
I think you might as well play the most
magnificent game you can while you're
waiting because do you have anything
better to do really why not pick the
best thing pause
that you could do why not do that maybe
you could justify your wretched
existence to yourself that way I think
you could that's what it looks like
you know people find such meaning in the
responsibilities they adopt it stops
making them ask questions about what
life is for if you have a newborn child
for example like unless you're really in
a bad way
psychotically depressed or or maybe your
personality really needs some retooling
you stop thinking about anything but
ensuring that that baby is doing well
and if someone comes along and asks you
an existential question about your
commitment to that the right response is
why are you asking me such stupid
questions when when the when this this
is manifesting itself right in front of
your eyes like how blind can you be that
isn't a time for for questions about the
meaning of life the answer is right in
front of you and if you can't see it
it's not because life has no meaning
it's because you're blind I mean that's
what the image of the Virgin Mother and
the child is all about it's like what's
the answer to the meaning of life here
is an answer it's like well I'm gonna
criticize that well go right ahead you
know it's like it's like what what
you're you're like a you like a what do
you call that a termite knowing on a
temple there's no there's no utility in
that sort of criticism you're it's
blindness and it's the same thing with
regards to the path of the hero it's
like it glistens in front of you and you
can criticize it it's like fine put the
cart before the horse and and see how
far you get so I thought to bring full
closure to the class I was trying to
solve this terrible puzzle that
confronted me for and many other people
about how it was that human beings got
themselves in such a tangle about what
they believed such a tangle that we were
pointing the ultimate weapons of
destruction at one another which by the
way we are still doing
and I thought okay well I understand
that we need your belief systems they
orient us and that means there will be
conflict between belief systems and that
can be a catastrophe and that's being
played out everywhere again in very many
ways what's the solution to that well
one possibility is there's no solution
it's just mayhem all the way around
could be the case but it seemed to me as
I delved into it that the proper
solution to that was to live properly as
an individual because you're more
powerful didn't you think way more
powerful than you think I mean god only
knows what you are in the final analysis
you're blind to your own weaknesses but
you're also blind to your own strengths
and so then I think well if you've got
your act together it'd be better for you
and instantly it would be better for
your family
assuming they wanted you to get your act
together and not everyone does but and
then it would be better for the
community it's like how far could you
take that if you stopped wasting time
and if you stopped lying and if you
oriented yourself to to the highest
possible good that you could conceive of
and you committed to that how much good
could you do well I would say why don't
you find out so that's what I think you
should do you should find out you don't
have anything better to do and there's
nothing in it as far as I've been able
to tell there's nothing in it but good
so maybe you could sort yourself out so
that you wanted nothing but the good and
and then maybe you could help make that
manifest in the world and maybe we
wouldn't have all these terrible
problems then at least we'd have fewer
of them and that would be a start so
it's the it's that the answer to the
problem of humanity is that is the is
the integrity of the individual that's
the answer so and states that are
predicated on that realization are
healthy so n states that aren't are
doomed to stagnation and catastrophic
collapse and personalities that are
predicated on
self tyranny and the tyranny of others
are doomed and doomed to collapse so and
then you think well what's the barrier
and the barriers are you willing to
accept the responsibility and part of
the answer to that is reduce the dam
responsibility until it's tolerable you
don't have to fix everything at once you
could just start by fixing the things
that you can fix or you could even do it
more you can do it with even less
self-sacrifice you could start by fixing
only the things that you want to fix God
you can get a massive way that way so do
it see what happens that's what you
should have been taught in university
right from the beginning
it's like aim at the highest good tool
yourself into something that can attain
it and go out there and manifest it in
the world and everything that everything
that comes your way will be everything
that comes your way will be a blessing
and so all you have to do is give up
your resentment and your hatred I know
that's a hard thing to give up because
you have plenty of reason for it that's
probably a good place to stop
[Applause]